ONE FINAL PLAY!
- GIVE ME THAT! IT'S
THE CUPCAKE WARS SEASON FINALE.
- HEY, HEY, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- UGH. I CANNOT GET INTO SPORTS.
- CHANGE IT BACK.
[click]
- AND THAT'S IT!
THE BEST PLAY
IN THE HISTORY OF SPORTS!
WHAT'S THAT, JIM? OUR INSTANT
REPLAY MACHINE BROKE?
HMM. WELL, IT LOOKS LIKE
IF YOU MISSED THAT PLAY,
YOU'LL NEVER GET TO SEE IT.
WE NOW JOIN THE BACHELORETTE
ALREADY IN PROGRESS.
- YAY!
OW!
YOU KNOW THAT'S A HATE CRIME.
[door opens]
- HI, BROWN SUGAR.
YOU GETTIN' PRETTY FOR ME?
- MAYBE.
- THESE ARE FOR YOU.
- OH...MY...
[shrieks]
GOD!
- WOW. YOU REALLY LIKE
ROSES, HUH?
- OH, WOODY, WOODY,
I LOVE IT, I LOVE IT,
I LOVE IT!
- I CAN'T BELIEVE
I'M NOT GAY ANYMORE.
THE BLAST FROM THE BOMB
MUST HAVE DONE IT SOMEHOW.
I WONDER IF...
MM...
UUUHHHH!
OH, NO.
MY LESBIAN STRENGTH.
IT'S GONE!
OH, MY HEAVENS.
I BROKE A NAIL.
- HONK, HONK.
WHY'D YOU RUN OFF, SEXY?
YOU LEFT ME HIGH
AND NOT-SO-DRY BACK THERE.
- UH, ETHEL, LOOK,
I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO EXPLAIN THIS, BUT...
I'M JUST NOT INTO YOU
ANYMORE.
- WHAT? YOU'RE KIDDING.
YOU'RE REJECTING ME?
NOBODY REJECTS ME.
I AM [bleep] HOT.
I'M AT LEAST A NINE.
YOU'RE, WHAT, A FOUR, A FIVE?
AND THAT'S ON THE GODDAMN
RICHTER SCALE!
- OH. LOOK, I'M SORRY,
ETHEL.
- YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I CAN BE WITH WHOEVER I WANT.
AND I WANNA BE WITH YOU.
- NO.
- OH, YOUR MOUTH SAYS NO,
BUT YOUR BODY SAYS...
- NO!
MY BODY SAYS NO TOO.
- HMM. PLAYING
HARD TO GET, HUH?
WELL, THAT GETS MY LADY PARTS
BARKING LIKE A JACK RUSSELL.
[barking]
THAT BIG, PASTY BUTT'LL
BE MINE SOON ENOUGH.
- OH, I CAN'T BELIEVE
I'M STRAIGHT.
THIS IS A DISASTER.
- EXCUSE ME, SIR.
WE'RE LATE.
DO YOU KNOW WHERE THE JESUS
HATES HOMOS RALLY IS?
- MOM?
DAD?
- [gasps]
both: CONNIE?
[woof woof]
- OH, NOT YOU, CONNIE.
THE BULL DYKE.